and then the other thing that got me
ticked off last night i'm reading that
you know the yucca the clown
yes for some reason he's not a clown
anymore now he's like a producer of
cartoons
yes he casts gary he cares gary
like and gary should probably just say
yucca stop using me to get a mention on
the show
but no no no gary tate grabs the job
there's no end to it i go gary yucko
hired you
one line he gave gary one line and now
gary's the poster for the cartoon
and gary's i mean right you're the
poster on the card there
i mean who gets one line in a show a 15
episode show and gets their own poster
right i i actually i i really didn't
think i was being used because i was
like it's
one line first of all they went to my
agent and i said you know you probably
should do this it's one line it's easy
you can do it from home
he can't do anything it's not like like
if he would have given me 20 lines i
probably
said no [ __ ] way because the guys
wrote me a note and they said yucca was
very proud of gary he
recorded his one line and he only
cleared his voice once and i go that's
not true because i listened to it like
10 times last night gary doing his line
his full throat clearing is not what
annoys me
if he just went i'd be okay with that
he just goes like this he goes
[Laughter]
here listen this is gary doing his
voiceover you got to listen carefully
gary does his little
give me the idea like like i walk in and
somebody's banging my wife is that the
premise
okay what the hell are you doing with my
wife
what the hell are you doing with my wife
what are you doing with my wife you want
to gilbert gottfried
what the hell are you doing with my wife
that's my my big impression my gilbert
what the hell are you doing with my wife
you want to [ __ ] around with anything
else gary's like a
flemy mel blank
[Laughter]
what are you doing with my wife do i do
it sad
what are you doing with my wife what
should i do with angry
what are you doing my wife
what should i do without gilbert godfrey
hey
what are you doing with my wife see
wait let me let me yell at yalco yeah
hey yucco
gary doesn't know any better to tell you
no so stop tempting him with those
stupid [ __ ] jobs to promote your new
tv show
all right all right full disclosure the
the suits
you know love you up there they love
gary they love the show
and uh yeah we we knew he would be
better than ronnie was
ronnie did a couple lines last season so
we we said okay we'll get gary this
season so but
gary i didn't hear the throat clearing
as much as you did
right we're trying to get you and
we know that's a [ __ ] no-go right
yukko says if i did four lines i'd get a
billboard on sunset boulevard
and then i see it i go [ __ ] yucco he
you know he he's smart he wants to get a
plug for his show
they want to they want a free like to
buy a spot is cost money but they get a
free play they just pay gary a couple of
bucks
and then the next thing you know they
they now everyone's going to tune in and
see
what is the name of this [ __ ] thing
paradise pd what the hell are you doing
my wife
go everyone watching on netflix there's
the plug all right thanks joko
hey quickly howard yes i made a
top three things that annoy you about
gary's
um taking that yucco gig go ahead
number three gary doesn't need the money
right i mean how much could they pay him
thousands of dollars yeah i'd love to
know what they paid him
too yeah and again this isn't me this is
what i think you're thinking
gary doesn't need the gig he's not
looking to become a voice actor right
he's actually taking
uh away a job from somebody who's
actually a voice actor
right number one
the fact that gary has an agent
[Music]
that's great yeah i know gary has an
agent
imagine you're at a party guy guys hey
what do you do for a living i'm gary
delabate's agent
oh so you do nothing too
how often does your phone ring what
phone
what phone
we had to cut back